hey everyone
welcome
super excited to share with you riffs
on the ineffable
it's exciting to
play in the space of
self publication
of content especially
given the tech stack that
amazon has
and so this is the first
self-published book on their platform
that i've created
it actually only took me one day
to make today and
i'm excited because it is very short
it's about
20 or so pages covering
just 10 brief simple
concepts an exploration of them
and yielding profound insights
simply by a devotion to truth an
investigation
into who we are and
what the nature of awareness is and what
the nature of
reality is what the nature of infinity
is source the absolute god
and so this is likely the first of many
of these
self-publications that we will be doing
which are exciting because
on top of getting this video content
where you can get the direct
dissemination of what is written in
the short book you can also
copy it directly from the bio of the
video all of these notes are written
there
you can pause this video throughout
as you'd like and also directly
draw out like an exegesis of what is
most salient for you
and also now you'll be able to
order for very low
prices we're making like a dollar or two
on each one of these purchases either
the kindle ebook which you can
then share the digital copy of or the
paperback
version which are both currently in
review but should be available
within just a couple days and the links
will be in the bio
and with the paperback it's cool because
you can just keep the nice little 20
pager
right on the coffee table or nightstand
and review certain concepts that we go
over here and just revisit these
profound insights if you would like
in the morning at night throughout the
day
to really abide in that god realization
so let's jump in
riffs on the ineffable
chapter one unity and diversity
you'll notice that everything here is
going to be very succinct
very precise very punctual very short
and that's the beauty of these short
books and the beauty of just being able
to just
drop right into that stream of
consciousness and just
transmit what's channeling through and
then
be able to structure it out
into even more distilled
and salient aphorisms and wisdoms
so here chapter one unity and diversity
take a brief look at our genetic
code here you'll find a
99.9 percent similarity
between humans and a 0.1 percent
difference very simply put
sameness and uniqueness
take a look at the eye
the pupil is our shared
being the iris
is our artistic expression
your unique coloration
every truth has been partial
we now integrate all variables
integrate all narratives
the collective and the individual
the left and the right
the east and the west
the indigenous and the modern
there has yet to be a story
a map that contains
it all all
of these layers
all of these variables all of these
narratives
a cohesive concise
map as close as we can
to the ineffable
obviously a massive major
life interest of this
unit its expression
is the creation and creative expression
of that
across all different styles of media
including the
immersive virtual reality pedagogies
animated series anthologies
why we're here in la
but also simultaneously a surrender to
the beauty of the mysterianism
that most intimate is not knowing
and that's the simultaneity there
to get as close as we can using art and
video
and storytelling around the ineffable
while also being
surrendered to the great mystery
chapter 2 what is time
props
look at a clock
and look before your
conditioning
see the squiggly lines
as symbols
before the creation of these symbols
what was time
strip the conditioning away
and what are you left with
eternity
what was meant to be a simple
coordination mechanism
became a cultural hypnosis
into infinity
supposed to just simply serve as a
coordination mechanism has
completely hypnotized
society into infinity
chapter three symphonies don't
play one song
universe means one
song multi-verse
means many songs
how many musical combinations
can you imagine
if your answer is endless
then you understand
our cosmology is that
simple
we're so busy investigating quarks
we're forgetting to dance
chapter four quantum mechanics
matter is what
appears
what is underlying is
energy
modulations fluctuations
of energy
how many combinations of
energy can you imagine
if your answer is endless
then you understand
our cosmology is that
simple
chapter 5 infants
before the name
what is a child
before telling a child who they
are who are they
what is that which is
before all layers of identity
this is the realization of
infinity
the ineffable absolute
lies before all
conditioning
strip away
the symbols
from a clock
strip away the name from a child
strip away the matter from energy
all that is left is the infinite
eternally modulating
strip away all layers
of identity
all symbols
all that is left is
infinity eternally
modulating
chapter six what is
love love is the recognition
that we share this eternal modulation
love is ultimate unity in
temporary diversity
love is the sun radiating
unconditional warmth
through endless combinations of clouds
the sun shines
what is observing
through you
is what is observing through
me
love recognizes this shared
awareness and cannot
inflict harm
this seer is
the ultimate and even it
is dreamed
chapter 7 dreams
a dream is an exploration
a play leela
in sanskrit the divine play
a simulated modulation
immersion into
first person view
requiring an observer just like
reality does
a dream is like a universe
one song ends and the next
begins
the modulation changes
but the observer remains
the same
dreams are many songs
just like realities are
the music is modulating all around you
can you hear
chapter 8 music
silence
between
notes
is like empty space
frequently unnoticed yet
provides void
quieting mind
gains access to
void
which yields
clarity
the notes are great
but so is the silence
refrain from speaking
and technology for one
day to feel it
yourself
ask yourself have i ever
for one whole day
shut my mouth and said nothing
and not used technology
quieted the mind
and observed what happened
became aware of awareness
became more subtle
the climax is not the last
note just like
the journey is not the destination
chapter 9 surfing
fireworks
every appearance is a celebration
a firework
do you wish to fight the wave
or surf
on the crest
are you counting sprinkles on your
neighbor's
ice cream cone
taste the rainbow
eternal combinations
of fireworks
unending blissful
peaceful wondrous
missing this is missing the expression
of life itself
chapter 10. one
two many
all is one
all is also two
all is also many
there is no separation
we are already it
there is ignorance and knowledge
seek enlightenment good
true beauty
there are individuals
unique creative expressions
of infinity
the one absolute is ineffable
the two are in rhythmic
balanced interchange
the many are actualizing artistic
contributions to the fireworks
this is true simultaneity
the ability to tailor
story to the exact
layer being discussed
to skillfully navigate
these layers is
jedi
all else is partial
truth
myopia unable to see
the layers
the one is also two
is also many infinitely
that's all riffs on the
ineffable that was a very fun
intuitive channel that came through
today also
just the ability to play with
the tech stack that amazon offers on
self publishing
and just getting into the flow with
getting more and more comfortable with
these little
20 page publications that
we can make a catalog of for people to
have
physical copies of digital copies of as
well as these videos
of and we will
continue producing content like this
and for those that are also curious
about high level perception
because i had satori on december 18th
of 2020 and that was literally right
before i was about to publish the
hard and soft cover versions it was
very profound that it happened to me
right before
the publication because
what that indicated to me was the
importance to
include the satori that i experienced
and all of these new visual
of the ineffable in high-level
perception
and so there are a series of tweaks
that are happening in these next couple
of weeks pre
the hard and soft cover publication of
high level perception
also so
and that is with a different
modern age publication organization
and so we're exploring what it's like
working with them
we're exploring what it's like with the
self-publication which is exciting
and so get pumped because so much more
is coming like this and
yeah great chapters too chapter 10
one too many chapter nine surfing
fireworks i love that one chapter eight
music the silence
between the notes chapter seven
dreams they give us so much insight into
the nature of reality
chapter six what is love
chapter five infants again
such a massive insight into the nature
of reality
chapter four quantum mechanics
massive profound revelation for us
chapter 3
symphonies don't play one
song
this is eternal songs
chapter 2 what is time
investigate the conditioning
and strip it away recognize eternity
that is our nature
and chapter one unity
and diversity all of these clues
under our nose 99.9
genetically similar point one percent
genetically different
the pupil and the iris all of these
explain like i'm five
child-like ways to understand the nature
of reality to understand as close as we
can
the ineffable a hardcore devotion to
truth
an exploration of simple analogies
and concepts yielding profound
insight thank you so much
i adore you thank you for tuning in
love to hear from you in the comments
below let me know how this resonated
with you would love to hear from you
if it brought you value like the video
if you haven't yet subscribe
also share the video with people that
you know this would profoundly impact
would love for you to do that
and we've already been getting
some memberships on the channel which is
exciting
and if you haven't yet look at the perks
available
under join on the channel some great
perks are available
check those out everything that comes
from you guys it directly goes right
back into the
vision of what simulation is up to here
in los
angeles and actualizing that global
enlightenment
that global god realization that
maximizing
human potential in this dream
adore you thank you much love
and really looking forward
to more of these excited
infinite love and adoration
eternal surfing on the fireworks
you